now that we have our competitive
analysis laid out we need to complete a
key part of our pitch deck and
coincidentally part of your final
project this is the value proposition
our value proposition is our promise of
value to our customers or investors now
it explains what problem our product
solves and what benefits were giving our
customers we need to frame our value
proposition so everything we learned in
this lesson is clear organized and
powerful the leading template for value
propositions and used today was written
by none other than Jeffrey Moore in his
book crossing the chasm so let's hear
from the expert himself when it comes to
articulating a value proposition we have
a template that we use in our practice
which has got six lines and it's proved
over the years to be pretty useful so
the first line is four and that's just
like who you talking to and we'll talk
about market segmentation but we're
going to talk to what we call the poster
child in your segment the per your
perfect target customer and the next
line is called who in that that
specifies the state that your target
customer would be in in in in wanting
your offer so the so you have for these
people who are in this state of mind
then the third line is called our
product or our service is and that's
where you categorize your offer
generically you it's a little bit like
what I'll and the supermarket would I go
to to find your product it's sort of
that sort of thing as in line three so
you're not trying to differentiate in
line three you're just trying to say
what what you are and then that and the
fourth line is your primary benefit the
thing that basically it speaks a lot to
the state in that the customers in
typically if the state is a problem
state this is the answer to that problem
kind of thing and then the last two
lines help position you against your
closest competitor so unlike and this is
where you put your closest competitor
and what's important here is that you
not pick a competitor that's that's
ineffective or not valuable to the
customer you want to pick a legitimate
alternative that this customer should
probably be thinking about but then what
you say is unlike this competitor our
offer and that's the sixth line and you
state your primary differentiation
and it's not that our offer is better
well it's typically what you normally do
with differentiation is you say they are
good for this and we are good for that